a local nurse at Desert Springs Hospital
is accused of sexually assaulting a
patient according to a lawsuit the
victim was assaulted multiple times and
then offered money to keep quiet records
from the Board of Nursing show the nurse
has an active nursing license and there
has been no disciplinary action a police
report was filed with Metro the nurse
was not charged with a crime the lawsuit
against the nurse in the hospital seeks
damages for abuse negligence assault
battery intentional infliction of
emotional distress as well as negligent
hiring and negligent infliction of
emotional distress